bismillah alhamdulillah Salam alaykoum
which means peace be unto you welcome to
another episode on the Deen show today
we're talking and giving you we're going
to be God willing giving you some
evidences some proof that the Quran
which was compiled over a span of 23
years which is revealed not just to the
Arab but to the white to the Chinese to
the African to the American it's a
guidance it's a book and instructional
for the whole of mankind my next guest
it's going to come out and he's going to
give this is a topic we can talk on for
days but in this short episode he's
going to give some of the top reasons
that you can ponder over to come to the
same conclusion that over 1.5 billion
people all across the globe have come to
that this is indeed not a man-made book
not a man written by Mohammed or any man
this is indeed a revelation for you to
follow to be successful not only in this
life but in the hereafter when we come
back my guest no man Ali Khan you don't
want to go nowhere be right back on a
Deen show love there's only one
how much is his messenger Allah like in
the world
ha there's only one bad and Jesus was
his messenger no I did that maybe it
maybe it's just to break the ice
Salaam alaikum brother Michael said I
will have to learn together how are you
very good
ha I'm glad and happy to have you here
on the Deen show or to be here and we're
going to get straight down to business
people who have watched possibly the
other show they know that you run the
Baena Institute for the most part I
teach Arabic yeah and I teach just
recently started a seminar on behalf of
an institute called divine speech yeah
which looks at the literary miracle of
the Quran so it looks at the Quran from
the literary linguistic point of view
and it's designed for english-speaking
audiences ok so they can so we have
actually your whole story of how you
really got used to be an atheist and
then you that whole story is on the
other show that we did with our brother
you can go on the Deen show calm and
look for no man Ali Khan he'll have his
own section there on the Deen show but
today there's some sincere people out
there they are looking for the truth now
they might have come from a different
way of life that they can sense they can
see that they're intelligent enough that
these are man's fingerprints all over
these different philosophies theologies
and they don't want to follow a man-made
religion so we don't want them to put
Islam in that same category yes so tell
us how would somebody know that this is
indeed a revelation from the Creator
that having a shortest quran display
establishing that the Quran is actually
from Allah from the creator of the
heavens and the earth the Lord and
sustainer and provider of all it's
absolutely critical for a number of
reasons for the most fundamental reason
being that if you are absolutely
convinced after some pondering and
research and reflecting on the evidences
on your own if you're absolutely
convinced that this is in fact the word
of Allah its the word of the Creator
then thereafter all the doubts are
removed so this is the fundamental doubt
that has to be attacked and has to be
tackled before anything else and once
this has been tackled with any other
issues you might have become irrelevant
so it's at the heart of
the matter now the Quran has been looked
at as the ultimate miracle by Muslim
scholars from the very beginning and
this is a topic that has been the
subject of Islamic scholarship for now a
millennium and a half from many many
many different angles some of those
angles that the most common angle is the
most difficult to explain in English why
because the idea is that the Quran is
miraculous in terms of its language
something in the way Allah speaks
something in the way that he
communicates his message is so profound
and incredible that it can't even be
translated the message can be translated
but the miraculous beauty of the words
can't be translated now this is the part
that's a long discussion you can't
really do that in a 30 minute or 10
minute give those things out tantalize
us so get us excited to want to go and
do more research ok now just to give you
a taste of this this topic the Quran for
example one of its unique literary
features is that the Quran a lot of it
rhymes a lot of it rhymes and you know
you could say well there's other
literature that rhymes but the amazing
thing is you have these extended long
passages the ends of each ayah or verses
it's called it rhymes and all of a
sudden the rhyme breaks and then the
rhyme comes back again right you know in
modern literature you have the idea of
paragraphs and footnotes like if you
have a paragraph and there's one comment
that the author wants to make that's a
sort of a tangent but you need to
understand it before going forward
they'll put a superscript 1 or subscript
and then they'll have something at the
bottom of the page or refer you to
another page or another book even the
Quran does this incredibly in audio form
meaning Allah is talking about a subject
all of a sudden he'll change the rhyme
scheme so the listener knows that this
is a footnote this is something that
before I go any further I need to
understand this footnote and then come
back to the original subject yeah so
actually paragraphs are even organized
phonetically this is incredible in terms
of literature that that entire passages
in this course is organized just by the
sounds that are being produced in the
passages now you can't translate that
but that's actually not what I want to
emphasize in this episode what I
really want to talk about our some areas
of the miracle of the Quran at least
three of them that are easily
identifiable and people can ponder over
them outside of the language issue that
make the Quran unparalleled and
miraculous the thing of it is to
appreciate what makes Quran miraculous
we have to understand the challenge of
the Quran the Quran actually issues a
challenge it says if you are in any
doubt in quantum theory be minimal as an
Arab Dena if you are in any doubt over
what we have sent upon our slave bring
something like it bring a surah like it
bring it bring ten surahs' like it bring
a Quran like it so the idea of the Quran
is if this is not from God you should be
able to produce something that competes
with it so let's talk about what how can
somebody compete with the Quran what
does that mean one way in which that is
understood is Allah says in the Quran
multiple times he says walaqad the
eternal core analytic this is number one
he says we made the Quran easy we
facilitated the Quran for remembrance
and also means for memorization for
memory lick now the thing is in this
ayah Allah says he made it easy he
didn't say the Quran is easy he said
Allah made it easy so this is some kind
of divine intervention here that makes
the Quran easy to be understood or easy
to memorize yeah now I personally have a
testimony to this but more than myself
hundreds and millions of people on the
face of this earth that are not Arabs
that come from very different ethnic
backgrounds children and adults of all
ages both genders without photographic
memory have memorized this book
beginning to end cover to cover all you
know in some print 604 pages all 604
pages exactly an identical form down to
the way they're supposed to recite each
syllable so just to give you a
hypothetical scenario if there was a
child in Australia and whose memorize
the Quran at the age of 10 12
I know 7 year olds that have memorized
the entire thing - and these are not
exceptional kids that's the amazing
thing this is if you train your children
you know this is a norm actually there
are some villages in Sudan and Somalia
where the entire villages memorize Quran
the mother the child the guy who
delivers the groceries everybody have
you met any students memorize to say the
whole Bible or what we have the Bible I
know people that know a lot from the
Bible but not cover to cover and it's
not it's not a cult
girl thing and there may be people with
super exceptional photographic memory
that are able to do so but this is Allah
making it easy for anybody or anybody
for anybody like for a good example
actually in my opinion a great example
is imam sahib webb who's one of the
great values he actually took he became
muslim much later in his adult life
started learning arabic and he's
actually already memorized the entire
quran o american who accepted islam
american who accepted islam traveled
abroad and actually memorize the entire
parents didn't speak arabic so - nothing
at all
so here what i'm the example i wanted to
make the australian memorizer of the
Quran meets a Chinese Muslim who's
memorized the Quran they don't speak
each other's language they beside the
salam o alikum which is the universal
muslim greeting to greet one another
they could say that much but they can't
really even ask each other how are you
doing because they don't have the same
language yet when these two people start
reciting the quran and one of them
recites the other one can actually
finish it he recites half the the ayah
half the verse the other guy can finish
it they know exactly what they're saying
for all 604 pages without even looking
at the text just just in conversation
with each other completely perfect
strangers meet up at the airport they're
praying together the guy leading the
prayer makes a mistake in something he's
reciting people in the back can correct
him and say no no actually it's this way
so even if somebody makes a mistake in
their memory hundreds of thousands of
people are there to correct so it's been
preserved it has Ehrman is there any
additions things different versions of
the cross so here's the next this issue
is very central the Quran is miraculous
in its preservation and Western
audiences have to look at this different
perspective our idea of preservation is
archives books parchment paper
documentation libraries transcripts this
is how we archive stuff right we are
arguing that a much more powerful means
of archiving and restoring document is
having multiple sources hundreds of
thousands of people memorize the same
exact document from the very beginning
so now you have for example if you had a
written copy of the Quran which by the
way like in ancient times in one city an
entire village maybe
one copy but thousands of people that
have memorized so the actual means
became members and why is that more
powerful because a transcript can be
edited right and especially there's just
one copy of it yeah but if you have a
thousand people that I know it by heart
I put it to the test I mean this is the
challenge of the Quran you take all the
Bibles in the world
all the Old Testaments all the New
Testaments all the dollars every all the
you know the ancient Hindu texts etc etc
you get rid of them
you hardly you put them away in a wall
in a vault also the Quran you put it
away nobody has access to these books I
tell you in the city of Chicago or in
the city of New York or in a small town
in Georgia somewhere even in the United
States we're not even talking going
abroad so long as you have one or two
people that have memorized the whole
Quran you'll recover the whole book in a
day the whole book we can recover it how
easy is that to do for for other books
it's incredible that the book is
preserved even if you get rid of the
physical books it's still around right
so this is the number one primary reason
of how the Quran is archived and imagine
if there were multiple versions like you
said if there are multiple versions of
the Quran what would happen is some
people would know a different version
than others right and so you would have
different and it would spread like that
yeah but what you have now is
consistency across hundreds of Nations
and hundreds of different people of
different languages reciting the same
exact thing it is imparted on in place
what you took some surahs out or you
edited some words and you this is your
own Quran it wouldn't last a day because
there's way too many people on the exact
same message talk about corroborating
witness right so this is actually a
miraculous means by which the Quran is
preserved as so long as there are
believers around and the literally in
the millions that I've memorized this
book you can't get rid of the Quran
that's the miracle that it is that is
amazing are there any kind of other
miracles things that are discussed in
this Quran that there's no way that
someone living fourteen hundred years
ago in the desert what you know it's
unfathomable that somebody can you know
make something up that we just
discovered today are there any examples
of this
see I'll give you another kind of
example the Quran speaks in very precise
terms it says well okay I mean I'm
delighted if the Quran was from other
than Allah yeah but one puts this
hypothetical scenario if the Quran
throws was from other than Allah Lalaji
doofy hasty laughs and kathira they
would have found in it a lot of
contradiction they would have found a
lot of contradictions in the Quran
what's interesting is obviously the text
is talking about contradictions in the
book yeah
but even the word is the laughs and the
word for contradiction the way it's
pronounced in that ayah doesn't occur
anywhere else in the Quran you you know
somebody could logically argue while I
found another instance of that word the
Quran says you wouldn't fall you
wouldn't have found a lot of
contradiction nor even the word
contradiction the magician might argue
even the word in 23 years of this Quran
being revealed the word is the laugh and
contradiction in that form in that
specific pronunciation doesn't occur
again in the entire Quran so the Quran
is it's incredibly precise in how it
speaks and imagine a person is speaking
and delivering a message for 23 years
what are the chances of him that him
avoiding that one word that isn't
supposed to occur the second time halala
similarly the word I had when Allah says
he's alone I had unique the word I had
occurs only once in the whole Quran yeah
and there are other mathematical nuances
for example you have salah baqara
mccullough is the second syrup second i
don't like the word chapter really we
should call it surah of the Quran it's
made up of 286 ayat common term versus
again I don't like the word verse I like
ayah better as I think it's proprietary
anyhow the in surah Baqarah there's a
verse that says well cathodic Ajanaku
matin wisata this is how we made you a
middle nation this is how we made you a
middle nation now keep in mind the Quran
is recited it's not documented this is
number one this is number two this is
number three that came later on yeah
that statement that we have made you a
middle nation occurs in ayah number 143
vassula that is a total of 286 thus the
ayah that says we you are the middle
nation occurs in the middle ayah halfway
through 143 is half of 286 of the surah
again an old tradition a Sulha that was
revealed different parts at different
times and compiled over a long period of
time and yet even then look at the
linguistic precision in the corral it's
a remarkable this is just one or two
instances of nuance there are hundreds
and thousands of them so the first one's
memorization yeah the second I can only
allude to which is really my main second
point is how precise and intricate the
languages but here's my real second
point as far as the quran is concerned
one of its profound most profound
miracles is actually the word quran the
word quran itself quran comes from in
arabic comes from the word cara which
means to recite yeah but the way it's
formed with that and at the end what it
really means is that which is recited
excessively one of the core meanings of
the word quran is that which is recited
excessively now think about this we're
living in the the age of mass media
right when living in the age where some
artist comes out with a song yeah and a
million mp3s are downloaded right and we
are saying we're arguing that one of the
things that makes Quran miraculous it is
that it is the most recited it is the
most recited now think about this you
have this song or this movie or whatever
that's on top of the charts yeah how
long does it say on top of the charts
not too long let's just give it let's
say six months which is crazy but let's
just say six months six months millions
of people are listening to this one song
and humming it and singing it whatever
energy is played out it gets played out
just one phrase in the Quran bismillah
ar-rahman ar-rahim one phrase well I
begin with the name or with the name of
Allah the excessively merciful the
constantly merciful right bismillah I
have another hymn is recited countless
times a day by millions and millions and
millions of Muslims every single day for
the last millennium and a half it's been
that it's been on top of the charts it's
the most recited word and it's actually
more read statistic that even the Bible
in the world and the Muslims are not the
majority population the Muslims are
minority as opposed to the Christian
community in the in the world and even
then being a fifth or less of the world
population this is the more
recited book come up with something that
can stay on top of the charts
consistently like the Quran that the
people won't lose focus and will
continue to recited recited recited
recited every single day day in and day
out it's incredible so this is another
actually miracle of the Quran another
small miracle on the side I'm gonna go
to the main ones but even before I get
to the main one side miracle the Quran
says about Mohammed Salim and says what
a fanatic at eight o'clock we have
elevated your mention he said no Quran
says about Mohammed Salim that he has
elevated the mention of the messenger so
I Salaam if you know about the call to
prayer in Islam the Adhan the event
includes the words eye shadow and member
home model or soul I bear witness that
Muhammad is the Messenger of Allah and
whenever we hear that we send a praise
upon the messenger sallallaahu audience
on up may peace and blessings of Allah
be upon him yeah
if you look at the world today Muslims
are all over the world
and you know how there are different
time zones no there's not a minute that
goes by that there's not an event going
on somewhere somewhere in the world an
event is taking place call to prayer
they are call to prayers taking place
and in that call who's it mention is
being elevated the creator of the
heavens on earth the creator of the
heavens and the earth and then dimension
of is the messenger his last and final -
last and final messenger is being a boat
that's being born witness that he's the
messenger of allah and people are
hearing it and elevating his status by
saying may the peace and blessings of
allah be upon him what did the Quran say
we have elevated your status so can you
imagine somebody else being praised like
this consistently every single day 24/7
globally across languages and cultures
and the largest one small statement in
the Quran we have elevated your status
and you mentioned and his mention is
taking place so ilaha illallah just by
that one phrase of the quran
unparalleled another praise is because
he was our teacher showing us just like
Jesus at his time was showing people
absolutely this is absolutely critical
the same thing is so we say as much as
we acknowledge and honor and show regard
to our messenger we acknowledge that he
is a slave of Allah that he's not the
one we worship he is the one we obey
because
God gave him revelation and he is a
human being just like anybody else when
actually he was commanded in the Koran
this is really critical he was commanded
in the Koran today or in Emma
Inaba show a myth local say I am just
literally Bashar means a human being
made of skin and flesh
it's literally referring to the mortal
being he's saying tell them unless
telling tell them I am just immortal
being like yours just like all the
message Jesus Moses knows like always
they have the same message worship God
not themselves the exact morter mortals
yes okay let's continue give us some
more okay this is so so you have this
was actually a side with profound
statement I mean come up with somebody
else has got higher celebrity status
yeah then the messenger of allah and no
matter how much you criticize him and
hate on him and have you know you have
documentaries made or horrible speeches
made by some you know some anti islam
groups that that spew lies and filth and
take things out of context against them
no matter how much you do that it still
doesn't reduce his praise any yeah it
actually continues to grow his mention
and his his followers actually continue
to grow so actually they're they're
actually fueling their own fire
subhanAllah Chinese we're almost out of
time give us another one okay amazing
miracles now here's one that because I
was a student of philosophy and also of
history it really it baffled me you know
the idea of when most Americans when
they go to high school we study about
revolutions right we study about the
French Revolution the Bolshevik
Revolution the Russian Revolution we
study in these revolutions we took when
we talk about a revolution we talk about
a society that had some sort of an
uprising against a regime and something
changed if you talk about for example
the French Revolution right it was
authority used to be in the hands of the
church and it was overturned and now it
was in the hands of the people so
popular democracy that was the
revolution a lot of people lost their
lives right in struggling for that idea
or that cause but in the end after that
revolution was done did people still eat
the same things they used to eat did
they still speak the same language was
there family relations pretty much the
same did anything else change
dramatically not not significant
the culture was pretty much the same the
overlying thought process and then it
over over a long period of time there
were significant differences in the
culture similar thing in the Russian
Revolution Russian culture before and
after the Revolution is very similar
what did change the economic system
change the Tsar's been overthrown etc
etc but now if you think about this
these revolutions that are great
revolutions in history that people talk
about let's take the Russian Revolution
the communist revolution is authored by
great minds like Karl Marx right Marx
was a German he lived sixty years before
the revolution happened did he ever
imagine that his book his writings his
ideas are going to get people to so
fired up they're willing to give up
their lives for this cause no he'd never
saw this I mean he's a thinker a writer
a library and even he's sitting in
library doing his research right he's a
thinker philosopher now compare all of
this these revolutions that are
political in nature sometimes social in
nature a lot of times economic in nature
these are what revolutions are political
social and economic compare these
revolutions to what happened in Arabia
like you said at the beginning of the
show in 23 years the Quran was revealed
to Muhammad slicin when he was at the
age of 40 it stopped being revealed when
he died at the age of 63 so it is a 23
year period the man who is presenting
this idea that no one should be
worshipped except Allah and he alone is
the authority that should be worshipped
and obeyed he presents this radical idea
to his community people reject him by
far but some people starting in joining
his ranks within 23 years this has never
happened before in human history that an
entire society has undergone a
revolution but it's not just political
and it's not just economic and it's not
just social it's also spiritual it's
also dietary it's also hygienic the way
people speak changed the way people deal
with their life changed the way they do
business changed the way they they
interact with each other with their
neighbor changed the way in many cases
the way they dress changed right the way
what they love changed and what they
hate changed what they wanted to live
for what
you wanted to die for change and the
government changed and the economics
changed like the big stuff change you
know when we talk about revolution we
talk about big stuff but life on the
lower levels inside your home it's still
the same but these 23 years brought
about this change in this society that
you can never imagine in any society in
such a short period of time and
completely revolutionize a society I
don't know of any document in human
history that is first of all the one
presenting that document in this case
Mohammed slice on them the one
presenting that document is also the one
struggling for its cause because all
these other revolutions are philosophers
and writers who died long before the
actual revolutions happen here you have
the revelation coming to him he himself
is struggling for this cause he's not
sitting in some library or behind some
couch and writing these things and other
people are willing to die for them he's
in front of the battlefield and he
brings about this profound spiritual
personal psychological social political
economic revolution in a complete way in
this society so much so it's already
ready to challenge other world powers I
mean look at Arabia twenty-three years
ago he's up the age of 63 right look at
Arabia twenty-three years ago it's a
place where the Persian Empire and the
Roman Empire and the Abyssinians they're
all surrounding the Arabs nobody wants
to invade the herbs you know why what do
they have they got desert there's
nothing there
why should we send our soldiers out to
toast because there's no resources oil
hasn't been discovered yet right this
these people were considered powerless
Bedouins that travel the desert and yet
in 23 years they are ready to challenge
the superpowers of the world and they've
completely revolutionized how they live
you have people that that were such
criminals that were you know they were
known for robbing and pillaging and
stealing before Islam and now there are
governors and there are treasurer's of
cities and if they find one penny
missing from the Treasury they're
willing to give their life up to get
justice for that one person complete
change in people this is one of the most
profound aspects of the Quran is a
miracle
it brought complete change that's just
the individual you know
when a person accepts Islam it's a
revolution inside that person we're
talking about revolution inside people
in their family in their neighborhood in
their society at every level within 23
this is amazing we got to just glance
over a few things that we mentioned you
don't have to go into debt because we
just have a couple more minutes sure
this was just entice people to look into
this further the scientific miracles of
how we were developed and other things
about the creation that was mentioned
1,400 years ago that we're discovering
they are indeed true today you just
glance over this real quick yeah this is
this is part of a larger subject called
basically the consistency between
scientific phenomenon and the Quran
there's a lot of research being done on
this topic in the arab world
specifically scholars like shakes landed
and ii have done a lot of work in this
area the one you mentioned the the
graphic and meticulous description of
the embryo as presented in the quran is
actually completely consistent with
modern scientific findings under a
microscope right and there's a great
book on it the bible quran in science by
maurice book wat okay so one of the
first you can see that they could they
could look up that book and my book at
quran and sign the Bible the Quran and
and science is a great book on this
topic maurice bouquet okay yeah so you
have you have that angle
another interesting of the hundreds of
scientific phenomenon that are in the
Quran just one quickly in a very curious
ayah in solar 57 Allah says well Angela
Hadid we sent iron down we sent iron
down here for mountains he says we
created mountains for the sunny side we
created the Sun we created the earth but
for iron he didn't say we created he is
a peculiar verb we sent it down I was
talking to a few geologists about this
and they said they believe that the the
iron came to the earth historically in
the form of meteors and was very deep
into the air which is amazing so you
know and and just the verbage of the
Quran and that he sent it down
subhanAllah so this in itself is a
consistent subject which actually isn't
my expertise but I'm very curious about
it I'm more on the side of language in
linguistics we've got one more minute
tell the people now what is this Quran
what is the Creator through this living
miracle that we have the Quran if they
submit to it what is it the benefits
of coming and doing what this book God
is telling this book on the one hand is
a miracle but on the other hand it is a
personal guidance for your life it is
personal personal guidance for your life
it guides you and it shows you the way
in your daily struggles and I'm telling
you this from personal experience and of
those that are close to me this book has
opened doors I know people that went to
the library started reading the
translation of the Quran and they came
back and they said I didn't read the
Quran the Quran read me this book is a
good picture of where you stand with
your Lord what you need to be doing on a
daily basis which is why one of the
greatest definitions of the Quran in the
Quran besides it being guidance is that
it's a reminder people forget their
purpose in life people forget what
they're here on the earth to do they get
dissuaded or they get you know
distracted by entertainment and by
movies and by YouTube or Vista that'll
do they get distracted into many
different things and here you have a
reminder constantly bringing you back to
your essential purpose thank you for
being with us again sorry we're out of
time we're going to have to do something
again with you absolutely I hope you all
got to benefit you heard the man he gave
you a few things that you can ponder
over you got to be what honest with
yourself you got to be sincere and ask
the one who created the heavens and the
earth and everything in this universe to
guide you to make it clear and it's
there it's very simple and we hope to
see you again next time come back here
every week at the Deen show calm until
next time assalamu alaikum peace be unto
you the DVDs for Dawa as Allah has set
in the Quran in surah now 16 125 will do
alas I be lit up because bill hikmah to
invite all to the way of your lord with
wisdom beautiful preaching and reason
with them in ways that are best and this
is a great opportunity for you to take
up the obligation take up the call as
Allah has told you to do and share this
beautiful message with the world
Islam submission to the one God let's
see what everyone's talking about if you
find one contradiction it can't be from
but the rational idea the rational
explanation is you do your best give up
for spring guidance I will never give up
spreading this message hope then you
take that necessary step you don't know
if you're gonna live till tomorrow so
you got to find that urgency to do the
right thing right now if you say that
you're not believe in Jesus you have
stepped outside of this man you cannot
be a muslim is that ended our faith to
eat scone Italy everybody sleeping I
arise and ask a lot of thinking may Omar
you see all our you know all the sins I
do I turn to you to figure my sin to mom
I'm a sinful slave you're my love alone
I'm the one runs away
oh look I me